"I think what GeT_RiGhT represents to CS:GO is the overarching rich history and legacy of CS itself beyond
just this iteration of the game."
(Casting)
GeT_RiGhT may be the  greatest Counter-Strike player in history.
His game sense...
(Casting)
And skill across multiple incarnations of the game are unmatched.
But despite his incredible ability,
(Casting)
Despite his unbelievable success, GeT_RiGhT is also
a player that has experienced more losses and more upsets than almost any other pro.
He’s seen it all, from roster disputes to poor placements, to personal illness
and through that adversity he’s still remained dedicated to Counter-Strike.
He still loves the game that gave him everything, more than anyone else.
This is his story.
(Casting)
Christopher “GeT_RiGhT” Alesund was born on May 29, 1990 in Sweden.
His brother, Robin, first showed him Counter-Strike when he was just 9 years old, and he was instantly hooked.
It wasn’t long before GeT_RiGhT began to attend LAN parties, and learning about the competitive
scene as he went.
But you can’t talk about GeT_RiGhT without talking about his biggest inspiration – HeatoN,
the captain of SK Gaming.
HeatoN was a legend in Swedish CS.
He wasn’t just the best player from the country, he was one of the best in the world,
Having won 11 major tournaments between 2001 and 2003.
Inspired by his hero’s success, GeT_RiGhT entered the competitive scene and
by 2007, he was playing in tournaments regularly.
And when his team, Gamepassion, won Rendezvous 24, he was quickly recruited by Begrip Gaming.
Once there, he started making waves with his solid play and great game sense which helped
take the team through the ESWC 2007 qualifier.
It was at that qualifier where GeT_RiGhT would get to face-off against his idol.
Ninjas in Pyjamas were a little past their prime, and HeatoN was closing in on retirement,
but none of it mattered.
GeT_RiGhT defeated HeatoN to qualify for
ESWC, and he was ecstatic.
"It was like just a good feeling to win the game and especially over someone you've been looking up to."
While Begrip didn’t leave much of a mark at the event, GeT_RiGhT’s performance signaled his potential.
GeT_RiGhT moved on to SK Gaming, then Meet Your Makers, then back to SK Gaming again.
While with SK, GeT_RiGhT didn't get much play time, due to a lack of team chemistry.
He was good and he knew it, but it was hard to fit in with the roster's older players.
After a brief stint with a number of smaller teams, GeT_RiGhT was approached by Fnatic.
The team needed a shakeup, and saw the young wunderkind as the guy they needed to put their
team back on the map.
And at the IEM Season III World Championship, GeT_RiGhT
helped Fnatic go undefeated in the group stage and brush aside SK en route to the grand finals.
And in the Grand Finals, Get_Right showed up,
(Casting)
Fnatic would bring down Meet Your Makers 16-13 to take home the $50,000  grand prize.
"At the Global finals they got off and running and you saw what was going to be the blueprint
for dominance that year."
"The supportive element was cArn and dsn, and then f0rest was revitalized early in the year.
And then GeT_RiGhT and Gux were incredibly powerfuk, and if they’re you’re second and third best players,
that trio is going to fucking wreak havoc, and they destroyed teams.”
(Casting)
"It was a very impressive year for GeT_RiGhT individually, he really started to show mad
fire power, in terms of just kills not insane aim or anything, he had good aim, and his
spray was very, very good – in 1.6 you could spray a lot more."
"And particularly to the latter half of the year he emerged as a potential star player.”
GeT_RiGhT would spend two extremely successful years with Fnatic, winning eight premier tournaments.
And while he was only a rookie when he won his first tournament with them, he was something
of a veteran by the time he left.
But with that departure came controversy.
In late 2010, reports surfaced that GeT_RiGhT, Forest and Gux wanted to bring SK Gaming’s
RobbaN and allen over to Fnatic, which would have shoved cArn and dsn off of Fnatic's roster.
"When Fnatic had this meeting, where the two sides made their demands.
The guys from F0rest, GeT_RiGhT even said you know if cArn's on dsn's side, which he was,
then f*ck it, kick cArn as well, get in two other players and we'll be the core,
And Fnatic’s decided (Fnatic's owner was very good friends with cArn) to go with cArn
and said cArn can rebuild the team,
and he let these star players – some of the best players in the world – leave the team."
So, F0rest and GeT_RiGhT went and joined SK, the rivals of Fnatic, at the end of the year."
"GeT_RiGhT didn’t miss a beat on SK, winning three premier events with them in 2011."
And as 1.6 grew older, GeT_RiGhT's playstyle become more refined.
He started developing a unique lurking style, moving around the map silently and catching
his opponents off guard.
Combined with his incredible spray control, GeT_RiGhT was an absolute terror to play against.
But as 2012 rolled around,1.6 was fading away, and GeT_RiGhT saw that a new game was going
to be the scene’s future.
CS:GO launched in August 2012, but GeT_RiGhT was playing it in tournaments while it was in beta.
And as he kept playing CSGO, he was approached by HeatoN with an incredible offer.
HeatoN, the man who GeT_RiGhT looked up to and defeated all those years ago, wanted to bring
back NiP, with GeT_RiGhT taking on a starring role on the new roster.
GeT_RiGhT brought f0rest with him to play alongside Xizt , friberg and Fifflaren.
They won their first tournament, SteelSeries GO
And then they won again.
And again.
The new Ninjas in Pyjamas were unstoppable, winning tournament after tournament.
From their first event in August 2012 all the way to their eleventh LAN in April 2013,
NiP didn’t drop a single map.
They had an 87-0 LAN map streak.
"It was just very cool and surprising to see that you actually can be so dominant in a game.
And also that you were the one of the best players at the same time."
"They were imperious they were unbeatable."
"And this is justifiably so, at the time it was the craziest streak in history.
"It probably still is in many ways the best streak, the sickest streak you will ever see in the history
of online competition."
NiP were all but untouchable in the early days of CS:GO, and that was partially thanks
to GeT_RiGhT’s unbelievable understanding of the game.
(Casting)
Even more incredible is the fact that GeT_RiGhT was performing at the highest level, all while
all while suffering an ear infection that required surgery, followed not long after by his diagnosis with
Crohn’s disease – a life changing illness.
"It's basically a sickness that affects me every day, every time that I wake up
It's actually a very different day. One day can be good, I have no pain, I'm happy, my medicine is starting well.
The second day can be like a living hell.
While NiP’s star player had been facing struggles outside of the game, the team began
to suffer their own struggles within it.
At StarLadder StarSeries V, NiP’s incredible LAN streak would come to a shocking end at the hands of Virtus.Pro
(Casting)
Despite losing their air of invincibility,
NiP would bounce-back, reclaiming their position on-top of the CSGO world.
Off the back of an impressive win at DreamHack 2014, NiP headed into ESL One Cologne 2014.
NiP were favourites at the tournament, and outside of a shaky performance on Cobble against
Epsilon in the group stage, they tore through the competition in the bracket.
And in the grand finals against Fnatic, GeT_RiGhT popped off, showing up with clutch after clutch.
(Casting)
The win meant everything to GeT_RiGhT, who couldn’t contain his emotions.
It would quite the only major trophy that he would ever hold.
Not long after their Major win, things started to sour for NiP and after continued losses,
they chose to forfeit tournaments and regroup.
The team dropped Fifflaren and brought on Maikelele in November, and while it worked
in the short term, the honeymoon period wasn’t
long lived.
The team failed to make it out of groups at IOS Pantamera, and replaced Maikelele with
Delpan in February for King of Majors.
By February 24 of 2015, NiP made another change, bringing in Allu as the team’s fifth man.
And just like before, the team’s recovery was all too brief.
"This is what I'm still talking about, the malfunctioning NiP."
By May, the team’s placements were becoming inconsistent, and despite a few scattered
victories at IEM Oakland 2016, 2017, and DreamHack Valencia 2017, that inconsistency continues to this day.
During this period, NiP’s roster has been a revolving door of talent around GeT_RiGhT and f0rest
the only remaining fragments of what had once been CSGO’s most dominant team.
But despite this seemingly endless period of adversity, GeT_RiGhT remains dedicated to CS:GO.
He’s still an incredible player and has been ranked in HLTV’s Top 20 players six
times in his life, taking the top spot twice.
And he’s shown that he is still more than capable of producing the incredible, ingenious
plays that have made him a CS legend.
(Casting)
Although GeT_RiGhT’s loyalty to NiP may have come at the expense of his trophy cabinet,
that quality has only added to his legacy and his admiration within the CS community.
“I’ve seen him with tears in his eyes, trying to make the right decision before.
He plays for the fans, he loves the fans, and the fans love him as well.
You see the emotion when he wins a tournament.
So, you can ride along with him on his journey.
And just the way he’s carried himself as well, in the highs and the lows, he’s somebody
that people admire for who he his as a personality.”
GeT_RiGhT is a Counter Strike icon.
He’s one of the game’s most recognizable figures, known for his brilliant play...
(Casting)
...goofy attitude...
"I don’t even know what that question was, but YES!”
and unbelievable dedication across multiple iterations of the game.
But that commitment to CS – his ability to keep playing despite every way life beat
him down, should be applauded.
GeT_RiGhT isn’t one of the greatest CS player ever just because of his incredible skill and achievements.
He loves the game more than anyone else, and that is what makes him so fun to watch.
That is what makes him the most beloved CS player in the world.
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.